bonsoir que le blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous alors mystère et boule
de gomme que signifie la découverte de
ces 30 millions de doses de vaccin en
italie oui je crois que ça signifie
d'abord que la task force organisée par
thierry breton pour surveiller les
usines les capacités de production
industrielle de vaccins sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
fonctionne puisque c'est eux qui ont
alerté monsieur draghi le premier
ministre italien et monsieur draghi
connaît l'adresse puisque il y a
quelques uns pape après à peine un mois
il a bloqué deux cent cinquante mille
zone de 250 mille doses de astrazeneca
qui a été destinée à l'australie par
conséquent les inspecteurs italiens ont
découvert que vous venez de dire 30
millions de doses qui est un
considérable ce qui vient de se produire
montre aussi que les grands groupes
pharmaceutiques ont une stratégie
industrielle propre qui échappe aux
états et c'est ainsi que astrazeneca a
conclu avec un sous traitant pour faire
fabriquer une partie de ces vaccins aux
pays bas près de leyde et que sais tu ce
sous traitant de l'aide
ensuite transmet son produit vaccinale
en italie près de rome pour le
conditionner c'est-à-dire pour le
flaconnage et pas de chance c'est là en
effet que ce stock a été trouvé pas de
chance parce que sans doute les pays-bas
aurait-il laissé les vaccins en question
partir vers la grande bretagne
monsieur draghi n'est pas du même avis
et il a déjà une expérience comme je
viens de dire en la matière alors 30
millions doses pourquoi 30 millions de
doses
c'est très curieux puisque en effet 30
millions d'anglais 30 millions de
britanniques ont été vaccinées mais ils
ont été vaccinés avec une seule dose est
maintenant deux mois plus tard ils
attendent la deuxième dose alors
probablement que c'est 30 millions
étaient destinées
au britannique c'était la deuxième dose
et ceci n'est pas très acceptable pour
l'union européenne puisque astrazeneca
ne livre pas les quantités qu'il avait
prévu par contrat par contrat signé et
qu' il ne livre pas dans ce cadre non
plus de vaccins fabriqués en grande
bretagne donc on en est là ce soir est
effectivement jadson a bien senti le
danger puisque il demande à négocier et
que lui voulait négocier sur les futurs
vaccins fabriqués près de l'aide aux
pays bas peut-être en partageant la
production mais je pense que l'union
européenne ne l'entendra pas de cette
oreille
alors le sommet européen qui débute donc
demain le vieux continent peut-il encore
sauver la face sur la question de la
vaccination c'est pas tout à fait
impossible parce que le conseil européen
va affirmer l'impératif de la
vaccination
tous les états doivent vacciner un
maximum et que pour vacciner un maximum
et doit recourir à toute l'offre de
vaccins qui existent dans le monde
naturellement à condition qu'elle soit
validée par leur organe de deux mots
location que ce soit l'organe européen
où l'organe des différents états mans ça
s'éteint c'est un premier point qui sera
certainement actée par le conseil
européen
je pense que la chancelière allemande
plaidera pour que l' agence pour du
médicament européen accélère ses travaux
pour valider le vaccin russe puisque en
effet la chancelière allemande souhaite
que ce vaccin sera utilisé en allemagne
est d'ailleurs ailleurs également en
europe et ce sera sûrement une une
discussion également importante
et puis beaucoup d'autres vaccins vont
arriver sur le marché dans les semaines
et dans les mois qui viennent et il faut
établir que l'union européenne est
ouverte à conclure des marchés
avec toutes ces entreprises qui
fabriquent des vaccins pour autant
qu'elles déposent des dossiers complets
à l'agencé européenne du médicament
il est entendu que ceux des états
membres qui veulent compléter leurs
fournitures en achetant directement sur
un plan bilatéral des vaccins peuvent le
faire dans la jamais été interdite
puisque de toute façon la compétence de
base en matière de santé revient aux
états membres
donc je pense que ce conseil européen
aussi insistera sur un troisième point
que monsieur byden évoquera certainement
dans son intervention en vidéo
conférence c'est le fait que il faut
vacciner les populations de tous les
pays du monde et pas seulement pour des
raisons humanitaires mais pour des
raisons sanitaires
parce que s'il reste des pays dans
lesquels le vaccin circuler de façon
virulente et bien compte tenu du fait
que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
l'ailé tout le monde tout le monde
voyage et ne serait ce que pour des
raisons économiques
tout le monde doit pouvoir circuler eh
bien il faut donc généraliser le vaccin
dans l'ensemble des pays du monde un
certain nombre de pays n'ont pas la
capacité financière pour se payer le
vaccin c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
avec deux autres organisations
internationales à créer kovacs qui est
une sorte de deux schémas multilatérale
et dans ceux de ses schémas
multilatérale et bien les pays qui ont
quelques moyens finance l'achat de
vaccins pour les pays les plus pauvres
d'ores-et-déjà l'union européenne a
parlé de 850 millions d'euros
je crois que monsieur ben dunn a évoqué
une somme considérable qu'il pourrait
aller jusqu'à 4 milliards de dollars
la france ajoute pour sa part en plus de
sa part du budget européen 100 millions
d'euros pour contribuer à ce schéma
kovacs les premiers vaccins kovac sont
d'ailleurs arrivés en début de mois de
mars en côte d'ivoire au ghana et vont
arriver au nigeria la plupart ces
vaccins achetés par le parle
par le ms ou par d'autres organisations
des nations unies comme l'unicef qui
sont chargés de télécharger la
logistique et bien achète la plupart de
ces vaccins aux plus grands laboratoires
du monde c'est-à-dire à l'inde en effet
astrazeneca a cédé licence de
fabrication à un grand laboratoire
indien qui est le laboratoire le grand
laboratoire de fabrication de vaccins le
plus rentable et brasseurs du monde est
en effet d'ores et déjà plusieurs
vaccins astrazeneca version indienne ont
été vendus ou distribués de part le
monde et je crois que c'est un volet
très important également pour venir à
bout de la pandémie
alors on le sait l'europe est à la peine
sur les vaccins d'ailleurs un instant
emmanuel macron vient d'admettre que
l'europe était un diesel en matière de
vaccination à une interview aux
journalistes ni cause pour la télévision
grecque
qu'en est il des voix des pays en voie
de développement
oui comme je viens d'esquisser les pays
en voie développement recherche l'aide
des pays développés pour pouvoir
acquérir des pratiques des vaccins
certains ont quelques moyens pour en
acquérir et en acquérir sans faire de
choix idéologique en la guerre là où
c'est possible et là où c'est possible
c'est à dire là où des vaccins existent
et là où la capacité de production
existent ils se trouvent aujourd'hui que
la capacité de production est répandue à
travers le monde en fonction de la
stratégie des grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques mais qu' un pays au
monde à une capacité plus importante que
les autres
il fabrique depuis beaucoup d'années la
moitié des vaccins du monde et ce pays
c'est l'un donc un dément indépendamment
des jeux d'influencé de tel ou tel il il
doit y avoir un recours aux mécanismes
du marché en passant par ce mécanisme
multilatéral et kovacs de façon à ce que
la pilule tous les pays du monde est
accès à ce vaccin
merci que des blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales